well I had I had a really good friend
who died Much Too Young Who was a friend
of mine at college and he simply could
not believe that anyone had the temerity
to call themselves an historian without
actually having read War and Peace So I
did immediately
um while I was actually having a a job
in the I was the only only straight man
in the soft Furnishings department at
Liberty so that's what led you by the
way yeah yeah so I used to go around the
corner to a veggie restaurant and get my
dose of tell stories tell a story what I
wanted and never look back very good
thank you and John
well I think it's all done for something
called Mr riggiani if I fear isn't with
us anymore but if he is out there I owe
it all to you Mr riggiani who was a
rather sardonic occasionally slightly
sneery English teacher
who did a wonderful thing which was once
a week I I think it was on Friday and I
think it when it was when he was tired
and bored he would read aloud to us
every Friday and that's what he did in
English and I remember the two books he
read aloud were Alistair McLean's forced
10 from Navarone
which actually was quite good and uh and
David Copperfield I realize now he must
have much Abridged it but it was just
hearing him read it out and um we're
gonna have a bit of David Copperfield
later but I'll still hear Mr riggiano's
voice as a kind of death count I think
so it so for both of you these were
pivotal moments a moment that this work
spoke to you at some point and became
you became sort of attached to it yeah I
think I mean I just say to to scramble
things up a bit my father used to read
Dickens every Sunday after G yeah
actually my dad's finally saved not
enough money to have his first summer
holiday and on the way to Victoria's
station actually ran into a barrow boy
with complete set of Dickens and he
exchanged his holiday money
um for that set of Dickens which I now
have so I'm you know this is an evening
tempestuous Conflict for me and divine
love Yeah Yeah divided love
we start now with John Mullen and
Dickens thank you
um okay so I'm going to play an
honorable part here and I I determined
before I arrived here that I wasn't
going to be oppositional all right you
want me to stand yeah
it's fine yeah okay yeah
because you're you're Target's good
that's good
I feel like Mr crumbles that's an
illusion
um
I thought I'm not going to be
oppositional and compare and contrast
and slag off or anything like that but I
I will after all I thought I I love
Tolstoy
I quite like Simon
um but I thought I would just say one
little thing about Tolstoy and Dickens
right at the beginning and that is just
anecdotal really which is a couple of
years ago I visited uh tolstoy's country
house he has Naya polyana about 150
miles south of Moscow and we were
getting it was a British Council bino
and so we were getting the sort of the
full tour and from a tolls toy expert
and I was shown into the room where
Tolstoy died where also his last place
of study and writing was and he shifted
his study around the house at different
times and she said she told us the one
thing that remained constant wherever he
was working and writing in his years in
the house was the picture above his desk
and you know what I'm going to say don't
you the picture above his desk was a
portrait
still there the very one and it's a
portrait of Charles Dickens
we could stop there could we maybe
um
it's a portrait of Charles Dickens and
he had it there every time he looked up
thinking what's Kitty going to say next
there was Charles Dickens
and that's because I think Dickens did
what I would argue he does to many many
writers but actually to all his readers
and weirdly even to some people who sort
of haven't actually read a whole novel
but have heard the words phrases even
bits of dialogue on TV or Cinema he
feeds our imaginations like no other
writer
I meant to say as a claim for his
special prowess the most important thing
about Dickens and the way he feeds our
imaginations is
he's funny he's funny but that's not
right that's not quite right
I think it's better to say
I decided that I change from the
Victoria line to the Jubilee line and
thought saying is funny is not good
enough that's not right
he's funny when he shouldn't be that
that's what's great about Dickens he's
funny at the wrong times in the
unexpected places where everybody's at a
funeral or a deathbed he's funny
and he himself had a description of what
he was doing when he was funny and the
wrong places at the wrong times and it's
in Oliver Twist and he says he's
comparing his writing very
characteristic of Dickens he's comparing
his writing to the stage melodram a much
despised by critics much loved by
audiences of his day and he's talking
about the way in a stage male drama of
his day just after a scene where
somebody's languishing in a dungeon
somebody will come on and sing a comic
song
and he says that his writing like such
melodrama is he says like a side of
streaky bacon
the tragic and the comic you see
absurdly alternate but as he says that's
what it's like isn't it that's what life
is like the Absurd and the comic
alternating alongside each other when
they shouldn't be
and I hope you'll hear that in our first
reading which has got quite a bit of
streaky bacon-ness in it I think
um it doesn't need much introduction
because it's the opening of a novel it's
the opening the very opening of Great
Expectations
[Applause]
country
down by the river
within as the river wound 20 miles of
the sea
my first most Vivid and Broad impression
of the identity of things
seems to me to have been gained on a
memorable raw afternoon towards evening
at such a time I found out for certain
that this Bleak Place overgrown with
Nettles was the churchyard and that
Philip pirip late of this parish and
also Georgiana wife of the above were
dead and buried
and the Alexander Bartholomew Abraham
Tobias and Roger infant Children of the
afore said were also dead and buried
and that the dark flat Wilderness beyond
the churchyard intersected with dikes
and mounds and gates with scattered
cattle feeding on it was the marshes
and that the low Laden line Beyond was
the river
and that the distant Savage layer from
which the wind was rushing was the sea
and that the small bundle of Shivers
growing afraid of it all and beginning
to cry was pip oh the noise cried a
terrible voice as a man started up from
among the graves at the side of the
church porch okay still you little devil
or I'll cut your throat a fearful man
all in coarse gray with a great iron on
his leg a man with no hat and with
broken shoes and with an old rag tied
around his head a man who'd been soaked
in water and smothered in mud and lamed
by stones and cut by flints and stung by
Nettles and torn by bryas who limped and
shivered and glad and growled and whose
teeth chattered in his head as he seized
me by the chin oh don't cut my throat
quick
Pips once more give me mouth
Pizza
show us where you live
put out the place I pointed to where our
village lay on the flat inshore among
the older trees and pollards a mile or
more from the church
the man
looking after me
at the moment
turned me upside down and emptied my
pockets
there was nothing in them but a piece of
bread when the church came to itself for
he was so sudden and strong that he made
it Go Head Over Heels before me and I
saw the steeple under my feet when the
church came to itself I say I was Seated
on a high Tombstone trembling while he
ate the bread ravenously
you young dog
well fat cheeks you go I believe they
were fat though I was at the time
undersized for my years and not strong
don't me if I couldn't eat them
and if you had enough of the mind to it
I earnestly expressed my hope that he
wouldn't and held tighter to the
tombstone on which he had put me partly
to keep myself upon it partly to stop
myself from crying no looky here
where's your mother
he started made a short run and stopped
and looked over his shoulder first off
Gianna
it's my mother
oh
yeah so and is that your father along
your mother
him too late of his Parish
supposing you're currently led to live
which I had made up my mind about my
sister sir Mrs Joe Gardner wife of
said he and looked down at his leg after
Darkly looking at his leg and me several
times he came closer to my Tombstone
took me by both arms and tilted me back
as far as he could hold me so that his
eyes looked most powerfully down into
mine and mine looked most helplessly up
into him look at here the question being
whether you're to be allowed to live
do you know what a file is yes sir and
you know what wigglers is yes sir after
each question he tilted me over a little
more so as to give me a greater sense of
helplessness and danger you get me a
file
and you give me Wiggles he tilted me
again you bring them both to me he
tilted me again or out of your heart
liver out he tilted me again
I was dreadfully frightened and so giddy
that I clung to him with both hands and
said
if you were kindly pleased to let me
keep up right sir perhaps I shouldn't be
sick and perhaps I could attend more he
gave me a most tremendous dip and roll
so that the church jumped over its own
weather then he held me by the arms
in an upright position on the top of the
stone and went on in these fearful terms
you bring me tomorrow morning early that
file and then Wiggles
you've been a lot to me and that no
battery over there you do it and you
don't never dare say a word or dare to
make a sign concerning your having seen
such a person as me or any person some
ever
and you should be lit to live
you fail
or you get
from my my words it means let me tell
any person whatever
how small it is then your heart and your
liver shall be tore out roasted and ate
foreign
trusting not just to Dickens but to keep
my secret weapon for
the two are entangled of course because
as I remember from Mr riggiani reading
David Copperfield what Dickens does his
childhood like nobody else
um but I hope you could hear the
streakiness of the bacon there
um
that incredible opening scene from Great
Expectations is a real place isn't it on
the Kent marshes you can go there
actually you can see the graves
um but it's also a weird place from a
fairy story
um it's a frightening uh episode and
it's also a comical episode it's those
combinations which are so extraordinary
so true to the Fantastic part of all our
lives
also you hear I think in that in that
reading especially in Tim's wonderful
impersonation of magwich what Dickens
contributed to all our imaginations and
our ears his idiolex as the academics
pompously call it the voices of all his
characters each one different each one
distinctive of themselves
um in the next passage however because
we're going to have quite a lot of
dialogue I wanted a little snatch of
something different but in a way just as
important which is
an example I sort of snatched out of why
the adjective dickensian has become so
easy a part of our language
dickensian as a word for all sorts of
things
um one of them being an all-embracing
adjective for the kind of force of his
imagination that takes a place in this
case it's going to be London and both
describes it and transforms it so now as
a little example of that Tom is going to
read from a section of the opening of
Bleak House
thank you
fog everywhere
fog up the river where it flows among
greenates and Meadows
fog down the river
where it rolls defiled among the tears
of shipping and the Waterside pollutions
of a great and dirty City
fog on the ethics marshes
fog on the kentish Heights
fog creeping into the cabooses of
Collier breaks
fog lying out on the yards
and hovering in the rigging of great
ships
fog drooping on the gunnels of barges in
small boats
fog in the eyes and throats of ancient
greenish pensioners wheezing by the fire
sides of their wards
fog in the stem and bowl of the pipe of
the waffle skipper down in his close
cabin
fog cruelly pinching the toes and
fingers of his shivering little Prentice
boy on Deck
John's people on the bridges peeping
over the parapets into a Never Sky of
fog
with fog all around them
as if they were up in a balloon
or hanging in the misty clouds
gas looming through the fog in diverse
places in the streets much as the Sun
May from the spongy Fields be seen to
loom by husbandmen and plowboy
most of the shops
lighted two hours before their time
as the gas seems to know
for it has a Haggard and unwilling look
yeah I mean the more Dickens less of me
the better chance I have evidently
um
I mean you can hear perhaps you know it
goes on for Pages it's all as wonderful
as that and you can hear perhaps what is
if you're a little critic so wonderful
about it because he breaks every rule
for how you're supposed to write he
repeats himself he personifies
gloriously and illogically he loves the
Fantastic those people seeming to float
in a balloon in the fog and a little
earlier in the in the opening from the
passage that Tom read
um he he allows him he's he's describing
how awful it is in November in LA and
London and he said it's there's as much
mud he says in the streets as if the
waters had but newly retired from the
face of the Earth
and it would not be wonderful to meet a
Megalosaurus 40 feet long or so waddling
like an elephantine lizard up Hoban Hill
it's the first dinosaur in English
fiction trivial fact
and it's wonderful it's monstrous
appalling and utterly comical with its
Central London waddle
um Dickens is fiction is full of
delicious grotesquery and monsters but
his monsters are such that you let but
he lets the reader see how they've been
formed and this next passage that zowie
and Julia are going to read is an
example of that it's from Great
Expectations pip who's age 23 now moons
hopelessly after Estella the
hard-hearted Estella who's been reared
by Miss havisham to be hard-hearted and
one day Estella and pip are summoned
from London by Miss Habersham to visit
them and they go back to satis house and
pip overhears the following dialogue
between Estella and miss havisham
thank you
at least I was no party to the compact
for if I could walk and speak when it
was made it was as much as I could do
but what would you have
you have been very good to me and I owe
everything to you
what would you have love
you have it I have not
by adoption
retorted let's tell her never departing
from the easy Grace of her attitude
never raising her voice
as the other did never yielding either
to anger or to bitterness Mother by
adoption
I have said that I owe everything to you
all I possess is freely yours all that
you have given me is at your command to
have again
beyond that
I have nothing
and if you ask me to give you what you
never gave me my gratitude and Duty
cannot do impossibilities
for love great miss havisham turning
wildly to me did I never give her a
burning love Inseparable from jealousy
at all times and from sharp pain while
she speaks to me thus
you call me mad
let her call me mad why should I call
you mad
I of all people just
anyone live who knows what set purposes
you have half as well as I do
does anyone live who knows what a steady
memory you have half as well as I do
I who have sat on this same Hearth on
the little stool that is even now beside
you there learning your lessons and
looking up into your face when your face
was strange and frightening me
Austin
no not forgotten
not forgotten
no but treasured up in my memory
when have you found me false to your
teaching
when have you found me unmindful of your
lessons when have you found me giving
admission here she touched her bosom
with her hand to anything that you
excluded
be just to me
so proud
so so proud moaned Miss havisham pushing
her away pushing her gray hair with her
who taught me to be proud
who praised me when I learned my lesson
you
don't miss havisham with a former action
who told me you told me to be hard
listen me when I learned my lesson
but but to be proud to be proud and hard
to me this happens quite shrieked as she
stretched out her arms
Stella looked at her for a moment and
with a kind of calm Wonder
but was not otherwise Disturbed when the
moment was passed she looked down at the
fire again
raising her eyes after a silence why you
should be so unreasonable when I come to
see you after a separation
I have never forgotten your wrongs and
their causes I have never been
unfaithful to you or your schooling I
have never shown any weakness that I can
charge myself with
you return my love
but yes yes
she will call it so
I begin to think that is still an
amusing way after another moment of calm
Wonder did I almost understand how this
comes about
if you had brought up your adopted
daughter wholly in the dark confinement
of these rooms and had never let her
know that there was such a thing as the
Daylight by which she had never once
seen your face if you had done that and
then for a purpose had wanted her to
understand the daylight and know all
about it
you would have been disappointed and
angry
Miss havisham with her head in her hands
sat making a low moaning and swaying
herself on her chair but gave no answer
or which is nearer a nearer case if you
had taught her from the dawn of her
intelligence with your utmost energy and
might that there was such a thing as
daylight but that it was made to be her
enemy and destroyer and she must always
turn against it for it had blighted you
and would else blight her
if you had done this and then for a
purpose
had wanted her to take naturally to the
daylight and she could not
you would have been disappointed and
angry Miss Heaven said listening for a
moment for it seemed for her could not
see her face but still made no answer
so
I must be taken as I have been made
the success is not mine the failure is
not mine
but the two together make me
I mean miss havisham's a monster you
kind of feel sorry for her don't you
that's his trick or one of his many
tricks to show you how people are made
and twisted and pip all the time is
listening to this and he too has been
made by his expectations into a
different kind of monster he's wonderful
at populating our imaginations with
these characters populating our language
with these characters I mean just think
that there are more characters in
Dickens who've become words in the
Oxford English Dictionary than those of
any other novelist
grab grind Bumble Heap pick sniffing
they become adjectives
Pub slappery nouns ish
best of all maybe Scrooge I mean it's
impossible to kind of face the fact that
he invented that it seems snatched out
of nature itself
um in the last reading I want to come
back to that strange mixture of the dark
and the comical the Grim and the funny
that is so distinctive of Dickens and is
the thing he shares I think with
Shakespeare the jesting in the graveyard
um Samuel Johnson said about Shakespeare
the mourner in Shakespeare as the
mourner tramps to the funeral the
reveler staggers from the inn and that's
how it is in Dickens where funerals are
almost inevitably inadvertently funny
um in this last passage which is from
David Copperfield
um we are Shay mccobba
David and you've got to the most
important thing to remember for this
passage is David Copperfield is 12 years
old in this passage his mother has died
and the ghastly murdered stones have
sent him to work in the blacking Factory
his one Solace is that he has lodgings
with the macawbas but then they uh Mr
mccobba is arrested as he inevitably
always is for debt and sent to the
debtors prison in this passage he's just
been released so there's a little bit of
Celebration and the company David Mr
macoba Mrs mccobba numerous children and
the offling the offling by the way is an
orphan from the workhouse who works who
is so Dan on her luck that she's the
macawber servant and uh
this is what happens
[Applause]
I passed my evenings with Mr and Mrs
mccorber during the remaining term of
our residents under the same roof
and I think we became fonder of one
another as time went on
on the last Sunday they invited me to
dinner and we had a loin of pork and
applesauce and a pudding
I had bought a spotted wooden horse
overnight as a parting gift to little
Wilkins mccawba that was the boy and a
doll for little Emma I had also bestowed
a shilling on the offling who was about
to be disbanded
we had a very pleasant day though we
were all in a tender State about our
approaching separation
I shall never Master Copperfield
revert to the period where Mr macawber
was in difficulties without thinking of
you
your conduct has always been of the most
delicate and obliging description
you have never been a lodger
you have been a friend
copperfields as though he had been
accustomed accustomed to call me of late
has a heart to feel for the distresses
of his fellow creatures when they are
behind a cloud
and a head to plan and a hand to ensure
a general ability to dispose of such
available property as he could May Band
Away with I expressed my sense of this
Commendation and said I was very sorry
we were going to lose one another my
dear young friend
I am older than you a man of some
experience in life and of some
experience in short in difficulties
generally speaking
at present and until something turns up
which I am I may say hotly expected
I have nothing to bestow but advice
still
my advice is so far worth taking that in
short I have never taken it myself and
who had been beaming and smiling all
over his head and face up to the present
moment checked himself and frowned the
miserable crutch that you behold
ER I say returned Mr mccobba quite
forgetting himself and smiling again the
miserable wretch you behold
my advice is never due tomorrow what you
can do today
procrastination is the thief of time
collagen
my poor papaz Maxim my dear your papa
was very well in his way and heaven
forbid that I should disparage him take
him for all in all we near as hell in
short make the acquaintance probably of
anybody else possessing it his time of
life the same legs for Gators and able
to read the same description of print
without spectacles
but
he applied that Maxim to our marriage my
dear and that was so far prematurely
entered into in consequence that I never
recovered the expense
Mr mccobba looked aside at Mrs macawber
and added
not that I am sorry for it quite the
contrary my love after which he was
grave for a minute or so
my other piece of advice gobblefield you
know
annual income 20 pounds annual
expenditure 19 and six result happiness
expenditure 20 pounds ought and six
result misery
the blossom is blighted the leaf is
withered the god of day goes down upon
the dreary scene and and in short you
are forever
flawed
as I am
to make his example the more impressive
Mr mccobba drank a glass of punch with
an air of great enjoyment and
satisfaction and whistle the college
hornpipe
I did not fail to assure him that I
would store these precepts in my mind
though indeed I had no need to do so for
at the time they affected me visibly
oh our time is sadly almost up but
perhaps
you could hear in that wonderful passage
that mixture of melancholy and buoyancy
that
um enjoyment and relish when you're
supposed to be serious or Grim that is
so distinctive of Dickens disaster and
hilarity together and actually I think
for Dickens as for Mr macawber what's so
wonderful about him
but language his language is his
consolation as it was dickens's